a popular character is some serious
legal threats and a glossy Netflix
reboot here's the real reason the adult
Wednesday Atom series all but
disappeared Netflix recently premiered a
new trailer for Wednesday a TV series
produced and directed by Tim Burton as
its title suggests Wednesday Adams will
focus on Gomez and morticia's teenage
daughter Wednesday portrayed by Jenna
Ortega as its protagonist but Netflix's
new series is far from the first time
the character has been expanded upon
originating in The Adams Family comic
strip from cartoonist Charles Adams just
like the rest of the Adams Family
Wednesday Adams has already gone through
numerous incarnations these DeLorean was
the first actor to portray Wednesday in
the 1960s sitcom that marked the first
of many adaptations of its core cast of
characters perhaps the most notable
actor to appear on screen is Wednesday
Adams as Christina Ricci who played the
character in the 1991 The Addams Family
film and its 1993 sequel Adams Family
Values some viewers might associate the
character more closely with writer and
performer Melissa Hunter whose recent
writing credits include series like
Santa Clarita diet and She-Hulk attorney
at law prior to her work on those two
shows Hunter created and starred in a
YouTube web series titled adult
Wednesday atoms consisting of short
scenes of the iconic Adams Family
character all grown up at the moment
however adult Wednesday Adams is no
longer available on Hunter's YouTube
channel where it originated and in an
interview with BuzzFeed adult Wednesday
Adams Creator Melissa Hunter Finally
Revealed what happened to her YouTube
series as it turns out Hunter was
compelled to remove the series from her
Channel after receiving a seasoned
assist letter from the T and Charles
Adams Foundation which owns The Adams
Family copyright Hunter told BuzzFeed I
have the right to counterclaim the
videos and get them back up and YouTube
would probably do that but the problem
is that escalates the issue and could
lead to a lawsuit but the good news is
still have the dress understandably
Hunter has been reluctant to pursue any
Avenue that results in legal action and
explained to BuzzFeed I'm such a pan and
that's why I made this series in the
first place because I think Wednesday
Adams is such a fun vibrant hero
especially for women but as of now the
series is unfortunately done while
Hunter's web series became the target of
a copyright claim an adult film parody
based on her work remains online as do
unofficially uploaded videos of adult
Wednesday Adams episodes in an interview
with Mike Elder on his YouTube series
box Angelus Hunter described Wednesday
Adams as part of her childhood identity
Hunter also said that adult Wednesday
Adams was a project she spearheaded in
order to put something out into the
world that was entirely hers although it
may be over past episodes of Hunter's
passion project are hosted on Vimeo and
still viewable on Hunter's personal
website for Melissa Hunter and all
involved the abrupt end of adult
Wednesday Adams was devastating to make
matters worse even when she tried to
keep her series alive in the face of
imminent cancellation the parties
involved simply couldn't make a deal
happen in a Twitter post from February
of 2021 Hunter wrote after my show got
pulled I tried to get the rights to make
it a TV series I was told it was
impossible I'm still sad The Gatekeepers
never gave me a shot Hunter's tweet of
course was in response to the Netflix
Twitter account announcing their new
series Wednesday however Hunter also
made it clear that she wasn't angry and
was instead happy that Wednesday
maintains a place of Pop Culture
prominence she tweeted I have nothing
against the creators or anyone involved
Wednesday is an icon whose story
deserves to haunt us all there are many
reasons to be excited about the Netflix
premiere of Wednesday but if you're
hoping for new episodes of Melissa
Hunter's adult Wednesday Adams you're
probably out of luck
[Music]
foreign